in bad reichenhall gibt es den lockdown
schon seit über einer woche aber mit dem
großen unterschied dass dort eben auch
kitas und schulen geschlossen sind und
deswegen kommt es zu diesen bildern die
wir gerade sehen die eigentlich an einen
traum er an von kerzen erinnert ja aber
das haben eltern und schüler dort
abgelegt um eben zu zeigen dass die
kinder unbedingt wieder in die schulen
wollen sie haben dort teddys abgelegt
kerzen schilder aufgestellt und haben
von anfang an demonstriert gegen diese
maßnahme das eben auch schulen und kitas
geschlossen werden und eine mutter die
genau davon betroffen ist ist mir jetzt
live zugeschaltet das ist christina
hielten sie ist alleinerziehend hat zwei
kinder und wohnt eben in bad reichenhall
guten abend frau helfen
jetzt ist die zweite woche im totalen
locker und wie geht es ihnen jetzt damit
man gewöhnt sich an alles sagt ich mal
was ist sehr sehr schwierig vor allen
dingen halt für die kinder und das ist
das problem warum und auch wie sie dort
gesehen haben am landratsamt die eltern
jetzt aufstehen und für die kinder zu
sprechen weil die leute jetzt gab er
gestern die entscheidung das bundesweite
lockdown ab dem 2 november kommen soll
wie reagieren die menschen bei ihnen im
ort vielleicht auch gerade die betriebe
die besonders betroffen sind also
gastronome ja kneipiers wie reagieren
die dort anders als wir beim ersten job
dann kann ich jetzt mit sicherheit sagen
wird hier eigentlich ist noch passieren
die berchtesgadener stehen auf und ich
denke mal das was am landratsamt jetzt
gewesen ist ist erst anfang vielleicht
können sie noch ein bisschen mehr
einblick geben wie es bei ihnen aktuell
aussieht kita sind ja geschlossenen
schulen sind beschlossen sie haben aber
zwei kinder
jetzt weiß dass sie eine notbetreuung
haben wie geht es ihnen damit erklären
sie es mal ein bisschen es ist gut dass
die kinder nur betreuung sind zwar nur
bis 14 uhr unserer zeit ist bei 10 uhr
macht es trotzdem schwierig denn
geschwommen kulturministerium jetzt ein
system für den distanz unterricht wo ich
aber denke dass viele lehrkräfte die
wirklich ausnutzen wodurch meine große
probleme hatte höhere gebühren zum
beispiel gesagt dann hätte sie den
aufgaben nicht nachkommen müssen sie so
ganz kinderheim
ich bin sprachlos gewesen wenn tochter
hat geweint gehabt
alpträume gehabt und das sind immer kann
ich nicht nachvollziehen und das ist
einfach nur aufgrund dessen die ganze
situation und kann ihnen ja zu ziehen
ganz konkret noch mal nachgefragt
erreicht diese notbetreuung aus was
müsste ihrer meinung nach jetzt
passieren dass die schule jetzt wieder
geöffnet ist nach den ferien und dass
alles seinen gang geht ansonsten weiß
ich nicht wie das weiter funktionieren
soll gerade wir sind berufstätig wir
müssen arbeiten gehen ich muss aber im
moment allen auf für meine kinder da
sein ich habe ihn auf sich bei kindern
gegenüber dass ich die alleine komme ich
mit ausschließlich nicht nach und das
ist halt das große problem dass man als
mutter und dem moment immer zwischen den
fronten steht
wie lange halten sie das denn jetzt noch
durch ihre persönliche einschätzung die
woche denn wieder gab's jahren und
danach ist für mich sein soll so noch
mehr würde ich nicht schaffen um einen
kinder
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren